welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clements here to break down
episode eight
eight yeah this is eight so I'm here to
break down episode eight of She-Hulk for
you which was both great and amazing and
sexually liberating but also bad
horrible and once I get my hands on the
Intelligentsia I swear to God I'm gonna
wind up and punch him right in the
goddamn throat and thanks to Rocket
money for sponsoring today's video more
about them later we welcome local cutie
and bad boy Daredevil and LeapFrog and
get to learn a lot of new things since
we've last seen Matt also this mat is
super funny acrobatic and overall just
really fun it's really crazy so let's
just get into it because I'm sure you
want to hear about Daredevil as much as
Mt wants to hang out with LeapFrog we
open this episode to Jen and smart Hulk
from episode one discussing how Jen is
going to make She-Hulk work and yes it's
w-o-r-k but also
w-e-r-k you get it this is the first
time in an episode started like this
with the music before the previously on
card it's playing the song Work by
rapper musician and nerd Jalissa Wilson
we see Monahans wholesale which we've
seen briefly in the trailers and also an
homage to She-Hulk supervising our
Direct Dr Drew Monahan we see two
robbers stealing a couple linscock's
65-inch Smart TVs one is played by
Anthony Goolsby and the other is played
by Charles Barden who did stunts for a
ton of other Marvel properties so it
makes sense because he's about to just
get shoulder checked into this van by
LeapFrog right now so we're finally
introduced the LeapFrog well you know
like verbally because we've already seen
him before at Luke Jacobson Studio but
now we're like actually talking to him
also known as guard frog which I think
is a playoff of like guard dog I don't
know I know you probably heard me boss
or Mt talk about LeapFrog before before
a quick summary in the comics LeapFrog
was actually Vincent patilio the
inventor in Eugene's father he was a
pretty bad guy but once his father went
to the prison Eugene Don the LeapFrog
costume and swore to use it for good
Vincent patillo the dad was known for
going head-to-head with Daredevil Iron
Man the defender so it's not too far off
from what we see now with Daredevil just
now entering Eugene the sun once Don in
the costume was known as Frogman who
helped Spider-Man the Human Torch in The
Avengers that doesn't mean he was an
amazing superhero though that does not
mean that he was good at his job at all
don't get it twisted he was still pretty
kooky and Goofy that's why he's involved
in She-Hulk this family wasn't as
wealthy in the comics but in the
She-Hulk series they certainly are Jen
is interviewing Eugene patilio and her
office at GLK and H and reading a comic
book I think that has LeapFrog on the
cover also Jen's new threads are mwah
and the comics frog man and LeapFrog
have electric coiled Springs in their
boots giving them the ability to jump
super far and high not these rocket
shoes but my boy Tom Michaelson caught
this one when the rocket shoe starts
sputtering it's the same sound of the
Millennium Falcon hyperdrive fail watch
this
[Music]
oh which isn't surprising because they
use Skywalker sound for post-production
sound Services you Star Wars nerd you
also we get a call out to the impeccable
title and I guess leapfrog's catchphrase
which is time to rip it and rip it which
just reminds me of Beyblades and I
really like it once Jen finds out her
client is suing Luke Jacob since she
runs straight to Holden hallway's office
who says he doesn't want to upset Mr
patillo senior so we've got leapfrog's
dad now in the company Todd's also a
client so it's not adding up the way I
want it's all a little too suspicious
the very beginning I pitched Holden
Holloway was in on it all and it looks
like unlikely but it also isn't it could
still be happening also I theorized many
of times we've probably already seen
leapfrog's dad in episode 4. the merry
guy that hits on Jen and Nikki who I
know from Eugene and his father are
seemingly rich rich enough to give his
son a secret lair out of their building
or it could be a front for used cars but
still they're building either way so
it's good to note the sus Behavior
because it's very sus once Jen makes her
way to Luke Jacobson Studio he's working
on Jen's gala dress and Luke is not
having these false allegations he ripped
Jen's outfit off of the mannequin and
he's completely done with her we're back
with judge price who we last saw him in
episode one and three and in Swagger's
our good old friend Charlie Cox AKA Matt
Murdoch AKA Daredevil and before I get
any further I'd like to remind y'all we
have some amazing shirts at the epic
hero shop and we're releasing our
Daredevil merch right now this man is
back and we've got a new tea for him
called The Devil's Advocate and it kicks
ass more than ever Our Lady Justice T is
still here but it's going to the dungeon
soon so make sure you grab it before
it's gone get it all at the Epic
heroshop.com because it's gonna go quick
it's gonna go quick and it's gonna go
fast okay back to our regular
programming now let me remind you the
last time we saw Daredevil Matt was
mourning the loss of Elektra after the
Defenders while foggy and Karen mourn
his death death we get a lot of
Senseless Murder By Dex AKA Bullseye we
find Matt's mom bring Vanessa back in
the end we get an epic showdown between
Dex Matt and Wilson Fisk Dex buying gets
crumbled this goes back to prison foggy
Karen and Matt reunite happily
everything's blue skies and sunshine
then we see decks being worked on by
Kenji oyama and the rest is history and
as a reminder Charlie Cox said in an
interview that Daredevil born again is
like a season one not a season four it's
a whole new thing so some things may
spill over but ultimately I think it's
okay to assume not all of season three
will come to the MCU this is also just
an FYI for how we last saw him in the
bigger scope of things not with his like
Cameo that he made in Spider-Man no way
home and this Daredevils got jokes he
saw jokes in the Netflix series this
one's pure comedy this scene also
mirrors our free comics QR code and she
holds number four by Charles sule
She-Hulk is friends with Matt so much so
she goes for him for advice they later
go head to head Jen defending and map
Prosecuting Steve Rogers this is one of
my favorite runs they were both chosen
just because they're phenomenal lawyers
now Jen breaks the fourth wall calling
Matt an [ __ ] for asking for the
motion to compel production of The
defendant's Client List be rejected as
it's not relevant to the litigation
which is complete lawyer jargon mumbo
jumbo which is lawyer talk for first
things first Jacobson is not giving you
his Client List because it has nothing
to do with the case now this is when
they begin using a lot of lawyer jargon
and I'll be breaking it down like really
quickly for you because I watch enough
Law and Order She-Hulk says we need the
list because there's probably other
people who have been affected just like
this Matt says Luke's record for working
with people is top tier there should be
no complaints She-Hulk summarizes more
reason to bring clients to the stand if
he has nothing to hide then there's no
worries right Matt basically argues an
invasion of privacy on the client's end
where gen remarks this basically isn't a
private issue people should know what
they're getting into by hiring Luke
first where Matt retorts that Luke's
clients are superheroes which need to
remain anonymous at times and brings up
the sokovia Accords being repealed as an
example okay so this itself is already
pretty big news and to some small news
to others but to me I think it's a
pretty big deal as a reminder the
sokovia Accords were introduced in Civil
War the whole framework is to regulate
the activities of superheroes more so
enhanced individuals when our
superheroes even fought against it
remember they were sent to the rap so
this is not not just a little little
slap on the wrist this is a big deal the
Accords were seemingly still in place
even after the blip and even during one
division so now that we know they've
been repealed in 2025 because that's
seemingly when shio takes place that
means enhanced individuals can basically
do whatever they want not necessarily
like what they want but they could get
another Lagos incident or just not
having the closer monitor on how these
folks are engaging and saving the day I
mean does that sound dangerous to you
let me know how you feel because I
genuinely was team Captain America so I
was against the Accords but still what
happens when a bunch of innocent people
get hurt in the crossfire it just seems
like ooh a recipe for a lot of disaster
this is when the argument and trial
becomes more about Daredevil and
She-Hulk than opposed to Luke Jacobson
and LeapFrog they're arguing about being
anonymous to being well known while they
both kind of take Jabs at one another
it's clear their personal lives are
rolling over into this case also it's so
on the nose but I love this line he's
lying don't ask me how I know I just
know yes we can all tell his lie Mr
Murdoch we all know how Daredevil knows
Eugene is lying he can smell the fumes
and also hear the heart beat you guys he
is not a bat but close enough and
unfortunately Jen technically loses her
second case if you want to count the
Titania storming in and disrupting as a
loss and technically getting Donnie to
sign the cease and desist later too and
so yeah maybe two we're back at the
legalese bar and grill Jen's delivered a
green Appletini from Matt and I do
declare this man is giving me the vapors
also a green Appletini ah so funny I'm
green I get it he even later hints at
his new suit made by Luke Jacobs that we
can only assume is the new Daredevil
threads by Luke Jacobson Matt even
mentions Nelson and Murdock his Law Firm
back in Hell's Kitchen possibly cold
Nelson Murdock and Paige now right
because that's how we ended season three
hopefully they bring that over or it
just feels like kind of messed up to be
like Karen still works for us but her
name is taken off the headlines when
that says this Jen Walters can use the
law to help people when Society fails
him
and she all can help people when the law
fails it reminds me of in the comics
when Matt and Jen had a heart to heart
on how being an attorney can't go the
same lengths as being a superhero he
used this to break Felicia Hardy AKA
black cat out of prison when it was
proven she was framed and oh boy Jen are
we ever feeling this guy also when he
stepped away for that phone call it must
have been for Luke and he's handling it
so calmly as Daredevil does time and
time again that's when the worst thing
that could ever happen happens Todd
asked Jen for legal advice and they need
to talk ASAP immediately and he's being
a dick about it we're meeting Todd at
hoof and flower on Wilshire Wilshire is
long but it's in West Hollywood near
Beverly Hills am I correct it goes
through Beverly Hills so it's not
surprising that Todd is demanding to
meet there Todd is waiting sipping on
some red wine and a peep all those red
and black label Johnny Walkers behind
him he's clearly not here to talk about
law this is around the part he yells at
a quiet restaurant wakanda forever and
puts his arms to his chest yeah made me
completely uncomfortable he also
purchased an authentic wakanda War spear
at an auction which we can assume is
probably one to the door melange now
this part where Todd says they want it
back because colonizers took it from
them is a big deal and important to note
in the first Black Panther movie we
first see adult killmonger at the Museum
of Great Britain looking over the
wakanan artifact that's actually
vibranium this item was taken by British
shoulders in Benin but we know back in
the day a lot of Western Nations during
the war and colonization stole so many
African art pieces and rightfully
African countries deserve their
artifacts but people like Todd who
clearly love Africa want to keep it he
thinks he deserves it for dropping a
milli on it and taking a clearly
photoshopped photo with the damn spear
like a damn colonizer so if people are
suspecting black panther rocana forever
to possibly take place in 2023 or 2024.
She-Hulk is allegedly 2025. I think the
connection is that after whatever
happens in wakanda Forever there's
another step for wakanda moving forward
when I say this I mean in the first
black panther claw was clearly a threat
but everyone was mixed on whether
t'challa should stay or leave they
weren't as worried about the artifact
and in the end they started expanding
their Outreach now and wakanda forever
trailer we get the sweet line that I
love so much where she says we know what
you whisper they have lost their
protector now it's our time to strike
that clearly can be aimed towards a lot
of things but I think and play with it
is the idea that it didn't make us
weaker and made us stronger we as a
nation and when I say we as I'm talking
about wakanda I'm sorry I I just feel
like I'm from there and they'll be
doubling down on everything getting back
in order and moving forward like never
before and one of those steps could be
reclaiming their stolen goods maybe
we'll see some of that at the end of
wakanda forever I have to say I love
being a nerd but really going all in on
a fandom is expensive there's
collector's edition merch maquette VIP
tickets to cons it adds up pretty
quickly that's why I like to use rocket
money my favorite all-in-one finance app
and look here I've been only using it
for about five months now and the app
helps me manage my expenses and save
hundreds because you know I'm always
buying clothes always buying merch and
always buying subscriptions I am
addicted to it so I can spend money on
what matters to me one of Rocket money's
best features that it helps you find and
cancel all your unwanted subscriptions
and I know you have a a lot of secret
subscriptions that you keep forgetting
to unsubscribe to come on just get it
just get it over with the app I
discovered I was wasting hundreds
thousands every month on stuff I didn't
even use with the money I've saved from
canceling those subscription I freed up
lots of money from going to movies
that's one of the things I do a lot of I
also like spending a lot of money on
bike supplies because I like biking I
also really like their smart savings
account and their budget tool with the
smart savings account you choose the
amount you want to save and how
frequently rocket money will
automatically deposit your money into
your savings fund that you can withdraw
from at any time with the budgeting tool
you can automatically monitor your
spending by category get notifications
when you've exceeded your spending
limits and visualize your spend to earn
ratio by month quarter or year yeah here
if you're feeling really super ambitious
rocket money can even negotiate your
bills for you from internet service
bills to cable and phone bills simply by
uploading a photo and tapping a button
and I know spectrum and Comcast is
running those bills up so get on it you
can unlock even more features in the
premium too once you've signed up 3.4
million people use rocket money to save
with just a few simple Taps and you
could be one of them too if you want to
start managing your finances the easy
way like me you need this app to try
rocking money out for free and support
our Channel head to rocketmoney.com new
rockstars or click the link in the video
description down below that's
rocketmoney.com new rockstars save your
money save it we also learn in the scene
that Todd studied abroad in wakanda this
could be why Ruby Williams is in wakanda
in the first place she could be studying
abroad also in the comics Brody from
Miss Marvel left to study abroad in
wakanda this will probably be Tethered
to their Outreach and helping those
outside of wakanda we see Jen's suit
which has been many upon many upon many
variations of in the comics but I like
this one the most because it feels more
practical you know if I had a leotard
from the comics you know it'll be flimsy
all my bits and chips will be all over
the place so yes we like practicality in
women's fighting fits it's what we want
of course Jen's strong enough to stop a
car with her calf she basically shoulder
checked them in the comics and also no
Daredevil's acrobatic nature we don't
see much of this in the Netflix series
but he was always very acrobatic in the
comics now I know we've been waiting for
this for a long time and we all know
about his suit change but you know it's
a breakdown so I have to talk about it
so Daredevil is now wearing a red and
yellow suit instead of his normal red
and black we've seen before now it
doesn't stray too far from the comic's
depiction but also good to note that
this is a Luke Jacobson original not
Melvin Potter also Daredevil really said
my ass remains unwoofed I just love how
funny he is also yes he was still very
funny has sense of humor in the
Daredevil series when he wasn't so
brooding but here he's not that brooding
after fighting in the parking lot which
I refer to as the dance of the soups we
see a poster for Rogers the musical and
Despierta news which we've seen on a
couple other episodes and a giant poster
for Donnie Blaze if you remember him
back from episode 4. also again not
Jen's first time lifting a car you guys
we saw her doing I credit scene that one
episode also this is happening and
LeapFrog is speeding past Avis on Flower
Street in downtown Los Angeles once Jen
finds out Daredevil is actually a Matt
she questions his power like
echolocation which we know is like he
has radar sense but it's maybe it's just
easier to be like yeah I'm like a bat
it's echo location also Jen says this I
assume the guy dressed as the devil was
the bad one which could also be a nod to
Bullseye from Daredevil season 3 who is
the bad guy dressed up like a devil
running around town also it plays
Daredevil's sick intro and I'm stoked
we're all stoked gold devil
I'm Daredevil they clearly haven't
changed it from the Netflix series which
I'm so excited for and in super bogus
news Jed has never heard of Daredevil
before maybe because his heroic Feats
don't reach the West Coast or maybe
because they're so small in Hell's
Kitchen it's nothing to California
there's also been a lot of stuff
happening in between these two shows so
it's not surprising that Jen doesn't
know who he is and maybe that'll give
way to the future of the MCU when he
shows up they take Jen's Prius that's
clearly been fixed since last episode to
the lily pad which is his secret lair
Eugene batillios and you can tell by
their family's name on the side of the
building and Peep the We Buy Houses QR
code that leads you to the Charles sule
run of She-Hulk 2014 issue number nine
that I talked about earlier my favorite
issue
I gotta do that every time now I hate to
be this person but LeapFrog secret lair
is sick as hell the old school LeapFrog
art on the wall the sticker on the
computer a completely green secret Labs
gamer chair the yellow diving helmet
which I don't know of any Marvel
characters that wear the yellow diving
helmet other than Mysterio thank you
Brandon but I do know this is a swampy
inspired Lair so maybe they pulled
inspiration from Scooby-Doo we have the
brass frog lamp frog parking only
LeapFrog Beacon Light like Batman's
little signal little LeapFrog game on
the table a green motorcycle Frogger and
leap Frogger at first I thought the
Frogger sign was just posted over
another game but it actually just
genuinely looks like that a greenish
trampoline clearly a lily pad and a
little child park riding frog this man
said if it's green or if it's a frog put
it in my Lair either way he indeed did
kidnap blue Jacobson for a minute I
didn't believe I was like maybe it was a
mistake maybe it was the dad but no he
he stole a man he stole Luke Jacobson he
tells Luke and wants his new suit to
have bulletproof Shields a fancy AI with
a British voice most likely a nod to
Iron Man and Jarvis also peep this lamp
with all the old school LeapFrog
stickers it's just like swagged out
Daredevil brings up the difference
between henchmen and goons that I love
and never noticed that henchmen believe
in the cause goons are just there for
the paycheck and that's great to keep in
mind also okay oh my god when Daredevil
listens to Jen's a heartbeat nah like
come on are you kidding me baby Christ I
need like an ice bath after that and
we're back at it our boys fighting
people in the long hallway again don't
we just love these scenes where he's
always fighting people in hallways and
the lights are just contrasting
everything I just love it really clubs
extend and have the special steel fiber
cable that allows it to shoot out you're
seeing during the fight we see this also
I think in season two the walkie-talkie
says Cobra and before we start going
crazy about what Cobra is Cobra
disgusting because it's not the first
time we see it in this episode trust me
we also see it on LeapFrog seat belts
but I think it's because his car is
modeled after the 1960s Shelby Cobra
also Cobra is the brand of
walkie-talkies so don't don't read too
much into it unless he's just a fan of
that brand this is the scene we got from
the trailer so now it's clear that these
are leapfrog's goons we've got a
crossbow guy a crowbar guy a sort of
grappling hook on a chain guy you know
those kinds of people are wild this
squad of tadpoles is Messy as the record
crew and very misplaced they don't know
their weapons they just don't even know
what they're doing we're ready for this
Throwdown another hallway fight
everything we wanted this blue light
casted upon us we are amped and then all
of a sudden freaking She-Hulk falls
through the ceiling smashing the goons
with debris with our very own new
She-Hulk catchphrase I guess She-Hulk
smash
and yes Jen he's doing it for all of us
he's doing it for you he's doing it for
me we're all into this we all want to
have sex with him too and just like his
father in the comics LeapFrog jumps out
the window breaking his legs now this is
maybe the funniest and most embarrassing
thing I've ever seen done in a comic and
if you've seen worse please at me try to
because
LeapFrog jumping out of a window and
breaking his legs and the comics is very
funny
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] the sexual attention
was real we weren't reading too much
into it not me screaming at Daredevils
clothes lining the ground like those
little kids dropping the breadcrumbs I a
God good Lord Cody you done wrote us an
episode you done wrote us an episode and
I love it baby thank you Cody thank you
so much the next morning the morning
after the Walk of Shame baloney
Daredevil's never been prouder also I'm
sure we'll see Daredevil again because
we have one more episode in Titania
posted this today which is Charlie Cox
in the same room we saw at blonsky's
Retreat so they'll be going back to
blonsky's retreat and we'll learn why
all these men are high-fiving in the
mid-season trailer hopefully like us Jen
breaks the fourth wall saying it feels
like the episode should be over and it's
not over I I feel the same way I I was
like we're all at this point right and I
think this is also really important to
note that she's never broke the fourth
wall this much being so aware that the
episode should in fact be over Jen
reminds us and is very surprised that
the next episode is actually the finale
which
getting getting all my kisses out before
it actually happens and a very writer
knowing situation right before the
finale usually comes the climax or the
twist and even Jen says it so we're
expecting the next five to ten minutes
to be probably horrific and they are
either way before we get to that part
they are teasing us about this red hole
she even mentions Red Hulk and we've all
been thinking about it we all been
expecting Todd to be red Hulk so if you
don't know Red Hulk was Thunderbolt Ross
in the comic books the Intelligentsia
gave Thunderbolt Ross the ability to
transform into the Red Hulk to better
fight the Hulk now and the comics we
really didn't know who Red Hulk was for
a while but we do know Abomination kill
Betty Ross with Thunderbolt Ross freed
him to kill Hulk and Thunderbolt Ross
spiraled but Modoc and the leader
offered to basically bring back his
daughter and also kill Hulk for good so
they injected Ross with gamma radiation
which turned him into the Red Hulk and
the leader when bringing Betty Ross back
to life turned her into the Red She-Hulk
I would love to see this play out
clearly in the She-Hulk series people
are expecting it to be Todd which I am
still banking on I will put money down
on top God turning into Red Hulk by the
end of the series hopefully Todd and not
like the leader Jen also mentions am I
getting fridged which is a term meaning
to kill hurt assault basically de-power
women in stories to boost the man's
storyline which if you haven't heard
you've definitely seen done shoot it
happens to Gwen's DC all the time you
guys the term was coined by Gail Simone
and ultimately refers to the Green
Lantern issue number 53 where he comes
home to his apartment and finds his
girlfriend dead and stuffed in their
fridge these storylines you can see in
situations where like the women didn't
really need to die you know Green
Lantern did need to overcome anything
because his girlfriend's death he would
have solved it on his own and what I'm
saying is this is just mainly in writing
it's not Green Lantern's fault it's in
the writing's fault so Gail created a
website showing every time women in
comics were used solely to push male
story arc rather than dive into their
own damn problems we're not a throwaway
device you guys you can't just use this
for your storylines the further him in
this way round out your characters don't
use us dying or being assaulted as your
ticket out my dude it's not that hard
yeah if you're a good writer you can
write that was my that's my rant about
being fridge because it's a it happens
this is still happens it happens in
every show just before we transition
Nikki is about to do Jen's makeup and
come on come on that's not the Wolverine
not I'm not having it we've gotten two
Wolverine Three if we want to count the
sneaker we've gotten three Wolverine
nods and now that we know that
Wolverine's coming into Deadpool three
how are you not gonna stop acknowledging
it if you're not gonna acknowledge it
you know I'm just I just I love uh
whatever we're at the Southern
California law Awards which we've seen
earlier in the trailer Jen steps out
looking beautiful in the silver dress
and heals the match the song playing is
the next big thing by West Rose we see
Jen's parents Elaine and Morris Walter
Holden is there and Peep Todd's hair
okay just remember that hair remember
the back of that hair because we're
gonna come back to it at the end Nikki
mentions Jen's dress being a Luke
Jacobson zuhar Murad collaboration and
I'm sorry if I butchered your name but
this is a real Lebanese fashion designer
not fictional real person we're table 14
and pug is also there Jen wins and so do
five other women I got we all thought it
was gonna be just one winner and it's
five Karen Hunter Alice Chen Joanne
Torres Barbara Wells and our good
suspicious just read Mallory book I
don't know if they did this on purpose
but each of those people other than
Mallory book are actual attorneys in
California Jen is rudely interrupted by
the Hulk King Emoji that's screaming and
it's like Pepe frog like I just I hate
this and a distorted voice breaking
through blaring do you want to see who
She-Hulk really is the intelligence he
is giving a speech about hating She-Hulk
like every Ransom video I've ever seen
made now I hate to do this but it's my
breakdown so we gotta talk about it they
pull up Jen's natural likes or text
messages photos of Captain America
during Civil War her bills and including
this video of her and Josh sleeping
together where Josh actually recorded
this horrible like revenge porn and now
it's being played for everyone at this
gala this is genuinely the most horrible
and completely messed up thing I've ever
seen in the world like it's it it's
awful it's awful adding people with like
nudes or anything like that in general
but like actually seeing it done to Jen
at this Gala and in front of her peers
clearly she deserves to be a Hulk and
Rampage also this scene could have been
triggering to some so I'm really sorry
it affected you and I wish I could have
tweeted out a warning but the way I
watched this episode is so sporadic that
it hit me at two in the morning Jen's
reaction is completely valid though and
Mallory tries to stop her and once Jen
breaks the TV the red alarms go off and
we can assume she'll look like the
terror tonight after the destruction she
just made sort of how Bruce warned her
in the first episode it's like the scene
from Carrie the lights are blaring red
and she Hulk's eyes are wide and rude by
shy girl plays and it's literally like
the Eerie Screech noise at the beginning
where Carrie's like they're all gonna
you it's horrible there's a chance that
this guy isn't him I I don't think this
could be Todd it might not be I mean
look at The Sideburns look at the long
hair kinda resembles Chad which I really
don't want Hillary could be the director
Noah but I'm banking for Todd I just
wanted to be Todd because he's already
an asshat might as well just make him
more of an asshat we get the law coming
in which we can assume to be the dodc
because they're jackets and they're
using the Hulk miniature versions of the
Hulk frequency machine we saw an
Incredible Hulk it feels like that but
it also feels like the machines that
they use and Miss Marvel new courtroom
illustrations are had Todd and LeapFrog
in the suit bidding on the wakanan spear
what we can assume is Daredevil and Jen
under the covers and Jen's knocked over
J mug and Daredevil's glove and suit
lying on the nightstand with Jen's bra
on top of the helmet Daredevil passing
Nikki on the not so walk of shame that's
everything I've spotted in the eighth
episode of She-Hulk you guys this
episode was really great I'm so glad
that we finally got Daredevil and with
so much great news of course had to come
horrible news but I know we'll get them
in the last episode we'll get them in
the last episode follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Lulu underscore Clemens
ball new rock star subscribe to new
rockstars for more breakdowns and
everything you love thanks for watching
time to rip it and rip it
[Music]